foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is James page in Madrid at the
ftth council Europe meeting and I've
been joined by Jacob Greiner from
Deutsche Telecom where he is Vice
President of European Affairs Jacob
thank you for coming and joining us
um we've been talking a bit about
regulation uh over the last few days at
the conference there's been two new
initiatives particularly come out from
the European commission what's what's
your take on them
it's actually it's actually three uh
called the famous telecoms package
um I would say first of all for somebody
who works a lot on regulation this is
the year to to be in telecoms because
um over the past couple of years we
didn't see a lot uh coming from a
regulatory side we had a bit of roaming
here and there and and other smaller
dossiers but now there's really a big
effort from the European commission to
put telecoms back in the spotlight and
they do that with three initiatives
maybe just to quickly explain one of
them is the so-called Gia the gigabit
infrastructure act what does it do or
what should it do in a nutshell it
should speed up deployments of mobile
and fixed in Europe which is something
that we highly appreciate why because we
still have today for example in our
footprint a very Divergent approach on
how long does it take to get permits and
authorization for example from a mobile
site that can take sometimes 20 2024
month or it can take four months and so
the commission tries with this piece of
legislation now to streamline to
harmonize this and to shorten for
example permit authorization processes
so that we can get the deployments
faster on the ground and I think that is
very very helpful to speed up
deployments and by that also trying to
reach the the famous digital Decay
targets which we will surely talk about
second initiative is the so-called
gigabit access recommendation what is
that it's not a law but it's kind of a
Bible a toolbox that the commission
gives to Regulators in Europe to say
when you apply the SMP access regulation
so what do we as Dr Telecom partly also
in in Germany have to observe what are
the remedies that we are going to be hit
by and this recommendation is very very
important for us because what is the
ultimate goal of it it should
incentivize
deployments in ftth in the future by
everybody
here we are not so happy to be to be
quite Frank this is still a draft
recommendation it will be concluded in a
couple of weeks why are we not happy
because we still think it's it's not
very future forward-looking it's in a
way backward looking and it looks a bit
like the commission tries to apply let's
say what they did with copper now to
fiber and we feel like this will not
give incentives to those investing like
Deutsche Telecom but also to our
competitors to invest themselves so we
see this a bit more critical and then
the last piece is very interesting and
it has caused a lot of discussion in
Brussels not only in Brussels it's the
famous exploratory consultation for the
future of telecoms it's a I think 62
questions that the commission is asking
stakeholders such as Deutsche Telecom
but also companies like Google meta
consumer associations everybody who
wants to say something here about what
is needed in order to shape or prepare
here the Telecom sector for the future
and what is needed to reach the
connectivity targets 2030 that the
legislator has said that we need to meet
gigabit everywhere 5G in all connected
areas and in this consultation there's
also a chap that talks a lot about the
issue of fair share or Fair contribution
what is it in a nutshell it is a
proposition that comes not only from
telecoms but also from the European
legislator to say we need to look at
Frameworks where all Market players who
contribute from connectivity from
infrastructure should contribute fairly
to it and the big question in the room
is does everybody fairly contribute here
or is it mainly the telecoms who showed
the Investments and shouldn't some of
the content and application providers
jump in and also dedicate some
Investments
thank you for for giving us that
explanation I mean one could look at it
and think that a sudden
Resurgence and of of Regulation and and
uh and consultations coming out might be
a sign that they feel that there's a
need for an acceleration here is there
is this is sort of desperate movies this
because the European commission thinks
it's not on the path to the digital
decade
so maybe I wouldn't call it not call it
a desperate move but let's say it is it
is a timely move and it's it's really
it's urgently needed why because there's
this vision and the vision is we need to
get these targets and it's not a you
know you could say well it's it's usual
in politics we have some ambition and
then we might not meet the ambition and
then we just do the same 10 years after
I think this time the European
commission really means it why because
they will even have kpis that they want
to follow in the next seven years to see
are we on track to get connectivity to
everybody at high speed as I said
gigabit everywhere 5G are connected
areas now that's the vision what's the
reality reality is is very very
different the European commission will
come out with a study I believe in May
it has already mentioned a number in
this consultation the number is 174
billion this is the investment Gap that
is there to reach those Targets on 10 20
30. this is a a massive number and that
means although we are all investing with
full speed it's not enough to reach
everybody my Association at no has made
a report with a consultancy to look at
are we on track to reach these targets
that report comes to the conclusion if
we continue as we do now we won't we
will probably not reach the last 10
percent that sounds little but it's 45
million citizens in Europe and so this
is I think what the commission sees
commission sees also that the sector is
um you know it's not Superman that we
would need it's a it's a it's a not
healthy patient I would say why is that
we invest a lot 50 billion per year
the problem is however that the average
return from the customer is very very
low compared to the US compared to South
Korea the return on invest is therefore
low and it barely covers the cost of
capital that we have so in a nutshell
the equation doesn't add up there's an
ambition that we should invest to reach
the targets we have a huge investment
Gap but at the same time the revenues
that we're having are not sufficient for
the sector to in a way meet this
ambition and I think this is what the
commission sees commission is now
committed to help the sector get back on
its feet why is it so important because
I think every end user every company in
Europe needs to have that Superman
digital infrastructure needs to have
that motor that is running in order to
meet the digital transformation and so
um we think it's very timely what the
commissioner has put now on the table
controversial
but timely and now let's have a thorough
discussion among all stakeholders and
and try to get to the aim that we all
want reaching those targets have
connectivity stable connectivity you
have ftth deployments in Europe and then
we're hopefully on good track
yeah absolutely and I think one of the
things that's been clear from our time
here at the conference has been how
this community is committed to those
targets but maybe we could talk a little
bit about the situation in your home
Market in in Germany and uh and where
Deutsche Telecom stands at the moment in
in dealing with those in dealing with
those issues how is the role out going
there
I mean if you look at Germany compared
to other regions you you have to say
we're we're not there where we should be
there are other countries like Spain
like France where fiber deployment is
already much more advanced at the same
time I would say there is a lot of fiber
competition happening lots of companies
will want to invest uh Dodge Telecom is
one of them we are committed to invest
between 2.5 3 million ftth connections
or households every year because we see
we have the same targets in Germany like
we have in the European Union makes
sense so we do what we can
but there's still a long mile to go
that's why you know a piece of
legislation like this Gia that I
mentioned beforehand might not be
something that every investor
hears or understands but it's our job as
as regulatory people to tell them this
can really
push the needle why because if it helps
speeding up deployments and oftentimes
the criticism is that's exactly the
problem that that these processes take
too long that the mayor of one city says
well I don't want you to open up my
street or I don't want this Mast on my
public property this Gia will help for
example accessing public rooftops public
infrastructure so that we can build and
deploy plus as I said it will speed up
this oftentimes very burdensome
authorization process so I think these
initiatives will hopefully also help
improve the situation in Germany but
we're not that yet there that's clear
also in other countries we're not yet
there deuts and Telecom is active not
only in Germany
but I don't want to say I don't want to
look at it too pessimistic of course and
we're all committed to to get to these
targets but that's why it's so essential
what's happening in Brussels these days
with regard to the telecoms package that
I explained
fantastic well no I I don't think you
came across as anything other than
optimistic and that we know there's a
there's real challenges but uh it feels
like everybody is pulling in the same
direction but um thank you for helping
to explain some of that regulatory
background on how things sit with
Deutsche Telecom at the moment thank you
for for coming and talking to us thank
you and I can just say I really enjoyed
those three days here lots of workshops
lots of sessions lots of interesting
people networking so happy to come back
again and hopefully interview uh have an
interview with you again we'll be in
your home country so it'll be uh it'll
be great if we can we'll love to see you
there great thank you so much
foreign foreign
[Applause]
[Music]